good morning my name is maureen bear and
i'm here with a set of colleagues from
starting up good
we're a pro bono organization that works
on various projects and we use wolfram a
lot and we have three presentations
today the first one is about Twitter and
social media the second one is about the
sustainable development goals and how we
use wolfram in that and the third one is
about structuring multiple data sources
so for the first presentation my
colleagues bed and kicker and Benji
Bernstein are going to do the
presentation thank you can everybody
hear me awesome and sorry I lost my
voice not the ideal day for that
hopefully you guys can bear with me
through this all right awesome so as
Maureen just sort of laid out for us
this presentation really explores some
of the ways that you can use Wolfram's
built in Twitter API connection to do
some really exciting and helpful data
analytics work that can really help any
you know user individual or organization
enhance their Twitter content and their
overall presence on the platform so why
analyze Twitter with wolfram so
obviously like I said service connect
really provides that built-in way to get
into the API that's extremely seamless
and easy for new users you can use these
analytics to make sure that you know
whatever content you want to focus on
your best positioning yourself for
success in whatever space it is you know
if you're someone like us we are SDG
counting and starting up good those are
sort of the two organization or you know
group names that we use for the types of
content that we use so we actually have
a Twitter account called SDG counting
which we'll be talking about throughout
this presentation and essentially the
idea is to really be an avenue to help
the UN sustainable development goals
space as a whole figure out where to
find the relevant
data and indicators that are really the
most helpful for advancing the space and
furthering it along so that the whole
world can achieve the sustainable
development goals by the year 2030 as
was set out in the agenda back in 2015
and then finally there's a lot of great
data visualization tools within Wolfram
that we found are extremely helpful for
this type of work and content and so we
we tend to really draw on those for the
type of work that we're doing to enhance
Twitter strategy and overall engagement
metrics so the first piece of this is
really the deep analysis of Twitter
content so what this really focuses on
is peer benchmarking so for example
again using us you know let's pretend
this is day one of our platform called
scg counting and we're trying to figure
out who are the big players on Twitter
in the UN sustainable development goal
space
what are they tweeting about what
hashtags are they using what are the top
mentions you know pretending that we
really are starting from a blank slate
and we don't really know what's going on
so we do a little bit of research we
figure out that you know the the twitter
handles that you see here global goals
Sun UN SATs UN s DSN those are some of
the big top performing peers on Twitter
within this space that really have a
platform and a voice that a lot of
people look to to learn more about the
UN sustainable development goals so we
actually built this tool to be able to
say okay what is it that they're doing
well that's giving them this platform
that's allowed them to have such high
engagement content on Twitter and really
become influencers within this overall
SDG community and so just gonna scroll
down a bit here and so what we're
actually doing once we enter those
Twitter handles into the code we've
actually created this defined function
called get tweet data and again the code
will be uploaded but basically what it's
doing is it's going through the Twitter
API
and it's getting a list of the most
recent you know 500 150 or so tweets you
can actually specify the range that you
want for each one of these organizations
and it's actually creating different
types of visualizations that tell you a
lot about what they're doing so for
example mentions word clouds hashtag
word clouds the types of texts that
they're tweeting about most frequently
their top mentions which you'll see here
their top hashtags all sorts of
different engagement metrics that really
give you a better understanding of who
are the key people what are the key
words what are the key content strings
that you should be talking about if you
want to become a serious player in
whatever space it is that you're
interested in so just then what's great
here is that we also have built a little
forum where you can then look at this
broad holistic data set and actually
zoom in on it to get a little bit more
so let's say I want to figure out what
is you know mentions word cloud global
goals Sun and again this is an
organization in this space that has over
300,000 followers there are obviously a
huge influencer who are the people that
they're mentioning that have led them to
gains this type of following and this
type of influence on Twitter so I can
come back down to this form see the
mentions word cloud and then I instantly
get a great visualization of the types
of people that are engaging with this
content area that I could automatically
start to mention in my tweets that might
be able to help me become more prolific
on Twitter and the content string and
again you know using these word clouds
that we all love we think is a really
powerful tool for being able to just get
right to it and understand who to be
strategically mentioning and then if
that is is just sort of the first step
what we also have is this ability to
blow out all of that content that you
saw in that data set above for each
individual organization and actually put
it into sort of a downloadable grid that
looks a little bit like this where you
actually can get a comprehensive profile
on the tweet
activity of any peer organization or
your own organization using a
combination of visualizations time
series to see the frequency of our
tweets so for example this is our handle
scg counting that we were talking about
you can see that in July and beginning
of August we were much more prolific on
Twitter had a little bit of a hiatus
probably not a great thing and then came
back in October to really be much more
active and what's great about this is
then you can compare these types of
profiles with the other organizations
that are within your wheelhouse in the
same space what I think is most exciting
for us about what this taught us is data
really is like a clear messaging area
that we're talking about when it looks
at our tweet text and and what we're
most frequently discussing and so you
can see very clearly here that you know
when people ask us what we stand for
it's really showing people how to map
and find the different data sources in
the scg space and figuring out you know
what what's the best different ways to
measure and count and actually keep
track of what's happening within the
data and indicator tracking and then
just the last piece I'll show you very
quickly and I think probably the thing
that we're most excited about here is
what we call the high engagement
analysis and so what we mean by high
engagement is engagement is a
combination of retweets and likes or
favorites on Twitter
so anything high engagement would mean
that it's it's a toast or it's a tweet
that generated a high amount of likes or
retweets and so what we actually can do
here with this little defined function
called high engagement tweet data is
compare the tweets of the peer
organizations but actually looked at a
side-by-side comparison of their overall
tweet content as well as their high
engagement tweet content so within this
defined function we can actually specify
the engagement limit we want to look at
and so here just as an example you know
we've we've picked a certain number I
believe we pick 10 here and so we're
only looking at tweets that have
received over 10 engagements for each
one of these different peer or
and those are what we're counting as
high engagement versus their total
sample which is their which is their
regular sample and so what you can see
within this data set and hopefully the
scrolling will work is that I can then
really quickly start to see a
side-by-side understanding of what's
performing well and what's not so for
example I have my top overall mentions
for SC G counting UNDP UN but then and
when it comes to my high engagement top
mentions it's actually a little bit
different than what we're seeing in my
overall and so this is a really helpful
and powerful tool that allows me to say
okay you know what global data lab and
SD SN trends are actually generating me
on average much higher engagement and my
typical top mentions I might want to
focus a little bit more on that and then
just to show you one more example for
global goals UN again this is an
organization that we saw had over
300,000 followers and is extremely
prolific and influential on Twitter they
would be someone I'd really want to take
a close look at to understand what is it
that they're doing that's generating
such high engagement for them so again I
go over to these different metrics over
here I see their top hashtags overall
within their most recent sample of you
know let's say anywhere from 100 to 500
tweets I can specify that and then I see
their high engagement top hashtag so
again global goals appears in both that
being said there's a couple others that
aren't necessarily appearing so for
example UN day it makes sense it's an
event so it's not appearing in their
high engagement overall and so this is
just a way for us to very quickly
compare and contrast to make sure that
we're actually using the types of things
that will give us the most content and
then I'm just my last word before I turn
it over to my colleague here is what I
think is the most exciting and something
that we've seen across organizations and
across peers is the percentage of images
and links that are included in tweets so
for example overall for SDG counting 17
per sorry
overall for scg accounting 17% of our
tweets include percent or include images
and links however for our high
engagement tweets again anything that's
received a combination of over 10
retweets and likes 66.7 close to 70%
have included percent images and links
so again you know and you see there's a
hashtag ratio mentions ratio you can
figure all these things out really
seamlessly through the data set
structure and it allows you to become
much more strategic and effective with
your tweet strategy as a whole so we're
excited about it and with that I will
turn it over to my colleague Ben about
how we can really use this suite
analysis data and talking a little bit
more Thank You Benji I'm sorry as you
can see we and if you've been to these
conferences before you realize that
Twitter is one of those areas that a lot
of people talk about because you can
pull in a pretty easy source of
information but what we found is it's
actually when you start combining the
functions you start looking at different
requests from Twitter you start looking
at different visualization techniques
that you can add a lot more to that and
so what binge eat Auctus how can we
compare ourselves to appear that we want
to be like or how can we move forward
and we want to be more influential in
our own tweeting but what happens when
you're new to the space you're starting
your own new account and you want to
figure out how can I establish myself
and that and so what we've done is we've
put a lot of emphasis on figuring out
who influencers are in the space so in
this case and this is a real life
example for us we've been working in as
the SDGs for quite a while but we
decided that we wanted to pay a little
bit more attention to blue tech blue
economy oceans and the sustainable
development goals related to that and so
there's a couple quick ways that if we
want to find out who is influential in
this area we can do it we can simply ask
Twitter
give me a Twitter ID search for blue
tech and then we can say give me the top
results from that and so we have one
input we can do in a form we can make it
fancy we can also say let's look at the
last 500 tweets about blue tech and I
want to know from those users that
tweeted about blue tech which of those
actually has the biggest influence and
we can follow
those but the problem with both of these
approaches is you have a relatively
relatively narrow scope of information
that you're bringing in you're only
looking at relevance instead of overall
influence or you're only looking at one
segment in time so what we've done we
started looking at is instead saying if
we want to understand who the
influencers are in an area it's actually
more important that we look at the
broader scope of what's going on in
Twitter and if any of you have spent the
time going through the Twitter API going
through the the service connect you'll
realize that Twitter builds in a lot of
limitations you can only get up to 500
tweets you can only request 15 friend
lists often it's time bound and so you
can only get the last 7 days or the last
30 days and so we wanted to start
combining different functions and
combining different queries so that we
could extrapolate even more information
and the idea for us is we believe that
if we know who a few influencers are we
know that as busy was saying in the SDG
world that you and Gaara
Euan goals is is a great one or I ISD is
another great one we can look at who are
they following because of an influencer
is following another influencer you can
bet that you've got some overlap and
then we can look at data related to
hashtags to see are we talking about the
same thing so in our case what we did is
we started with our own account and we
said let's take a look at who we're
following let's take a look at and who
is influential influential in this space
and let's start doing some analysis on
that
among those accounts we can then
download all of their hashtags and we
can say ok show me who my friends are
tweeting to show me what my friends are
talking about and we can see that a
picture starts to emerge about what
hashtags are actually most engaging or
most used in the space and so we say hey
we've got these 14 users that when we go
through our resources we know they talk
about what we're interested in and we
know that that they have enough
followers that there's somebody that we
should pay attention to
and so we download all the details about
these known
influences and you can see it ranges
from a thousand to a hundred thousand
but that doesn't matter because we know
that these people are tweeting on topic
if if you want to learn about impact
investing another area that we work you
can do the same thing there and figure
out who is talking about impact
investing and who are they following so
again with our known followers we can
pull their hashtags and say now what are
they talking about and this is a place
we can kind of check our math and see
like yeah we're talking about the same
thing so this is what we what we want to
see but the big jump where we start
going beyond what the Twitter API
provides and start providing our own
analysis is we do pull in the follower
list for each of those users so if I am
let's say that I am Scripps Institute
which is a great blue tech ocean related
organization if I'm in that space and
that's all I'm talking about if I look
at who I'm friends with who I think is
worth following we can start to build
that list and so what we've done is of
those 14 followers that we started with
we downloaded all of the list of who
they're following and then we
cross-referenced it and so in this case
we said okay anybody that's being
followed by at least eight of those
they're probably interested in the same
thing that those original 14 are
interested in so we do that we end up
with 123 people we can figure out who
those people are and you see we've got
some things that are tangentially
related to oceans we've got National
Geographic UN Department of State those
are our top three like it's nice that
they're being followed by the people
we're interested in but they're not
talking about oceans which is what we
want to know so what we do is we instead
look at the bigger picture of what are
those people tweeting about and the
easiest way to do that is to download
all the hashtags they use because what
we tend to hashtag is what we tend to be
talking about so we can download the
full list of hashtags for the hundred
and twenty three people that were common
friends among our starting group so in
this case we looked at and we said okay
if these people are talking about oceans
or marine science or our ocean or
capitol hill ocean week 2019 etc we
think that not only are they going to be
influencers but we also think
they're gonna be relevant to us so then
we can come up with a list of 50 to say
these are the people who are not only
being followed by influencers but are
also talking about things that we are
interested in and then we can pull all
of their information in and actually and
this is where the real power comes when
you want to sit down and start doing
analytics you can now start doing
analysis on the information that you've
already brought in so for instance if
we're looking at some of these 50 that
we think are good matches we've actually
added quite a few calculated columns so
we can see whether or not we're
following them that's something that
we've done by comparing our friend list
with with the list that we have so right
off the bat I can see that I have four
people that are relevant and are
influential but I'm not following them
so if I want to be in that conversation
I need to start by following those
people I can look at how often they're
talking about things that are relevant
to me if I decide that I'm going to
let's see if I want to talk specifically
about climate action so I want to talk
about people who are interested in
oceans and climate action I can go down
and find the user who most frequently
uses climate action along with ocean
information I can see what hashtags
they're using that are relevant to what
we're interested in as well as the
overall hashtags that are being used and
so I know that we've run through this
very quickly and we will post the some
of these examples online at the end but
the idea for us is that a lot of the
examples we've seen and using the
Twitter service connect have been
one-dimensional let me download text
language location and get X or let me
download all the tweets for this user
and analyze this but what we've seen is
that when you start crossing those
things over you start looking at
multiple service requests that you can
cross-reference with each other that you
can add to your own analytics and
visualization you can actually start
building tools that you can sit down
figure out how you can tweet better how
can you how can you incorporate best
practices that you've learned who can
you be talking with that is
most likely to retweet you how can we
get into a space where we're regularly
engaging on the hashtags that are
important to us now given that this is
only a 20 minute presentation at best we
have already stripped out a whole lot of
the work that we've done but we'd be
more than happy to talk with you about
what those elements are in a excusing in
addition to what we've we've shown you
here there's actually a couple other
things that we've done when we're
working with other individuals who are
trying to establish a Twitter presence
one of the first things we did was we
looked at who was following them and
then we said of those people who are
following you who themselves have a high
number of followers and of those how
often are they talking about your topic
and then the big piece is how often do
they retweet because if you can find
that user who has a lot of followers who
talks about what you're interested in
and regularly retweets if you reach out
to that individual the likelihood that
they will take your content and put it
out into the larger Twitter sphere is
going to increase the chance that you're
seen by more people we've also looked at
some automated tweet searching and
retweeting where if you're just starting
to count you want some content out there
you can do a daily search that finds the
top searches on a particular topic and
then from that it automatically retweets
the most engaging tweet so without even
doing anything you can automate that
process you can look at scheduled
Twitter searches so that at the end of
every day you have all the tweets that
are related to Capitol Hill ocean week
or BlueTEC or blue economy and the last
thing we've done is we've actually
looked at within our own data within our
own tweets what is it that we've done
that's had the best engagement so for
instance if I use the word SDGs versus
global goals which of those two tends to
have a higher level of engagement and
it's interesting we actually found that
SDGs has higher engagement than global
goals probably because it has shorter
it's a shorter string so we can actually
include more content in there so as
we're improving our own twitter presence
it gives us a chance to to include some
of these insights that we've had I look
it looks like we have four minutes left
but at the end of the day
this is a quick survey of what can be
done in Twitter less of a technical you
know explanation or demonstration but
yeah if there's any questions Benji or
myself would be more than happy to see
if we can answer you yes sir